With all the chickens coming in from outside,
I've been continuously making some sort of stock,
and I haven't been able to use that stock straight away.
So I need to can it. And I'm gonna use these wet jars to can now.
I've been canning for years.
Um, a few upgrades I've been having lately
is this amazing digital pressure can
I bug it? Back to that in a minute.
But I recently started using wax jars
and they're pretty popular right now.
I feel like I see them all over
of people using them for sourdough and storage and stuff
for leftovers or doing overnight oats.
But the best thing about these jars is that you can just cam with them.
You can reuse the seals. Are like normal pens
cutting jars, you have to.
Or any other brand of like that kind of style cutting jar.
You need to keep continuously buying new lids every time.
You can save the rings, but you need to buy new lids.
With these jars,
you can keep using the lids, um,
and then you just keep reusing that rubber seal, um,
to reseal the jars.
You can continuously reuse these until the seal starts to deteriorate,
then you could just replace that seal.
These jars are really nice and thick glass.
The lids are nice and thick.
I feel like it's very sturdy.
There's also a decent selection of different types of lids
you can get for them. You can Get push on lids.
Wooden lids. I've seen quite a few different ones
that I'm gonna try and get some for,
like, leftovers,
but right now all my wet jars have stock in them in the pantry.
So am I gonna have to get some more jars
or I'm gonna have to start using some more stock?
So to remove the lid,
you just pull this tab and then it just releases that seal
and then it's good to go. I would also recommend this digital canner.
It's definitely a nice upgrade from a regular one,
but definitely not necessary.